what is going on everybody welcome to
another python tutorial video in this
video what we're going to be talking
about
is a little bit more of modules and just
some sort of understanding of modules so
in the last video we're really talking
about the syntax that goes into
importing a module and all the kind of
nuances as far as how you can import a
module to do exactly what you want and
so you can kind of be lazy with your
typing now in this video we're going to
be talking a little bit more about how
modules themselves work we're going to
make our own module and we're going to
talk briefly about local versus kind of
like global modules so with that let's
go ahead and get started
first thing that we want to do is we
want to go ahead and make a
simple module
that we can use as an example so let's
go ahead and do that so as we've kind of
shown before
a module is just a python script usually
so
that's it so what we're going to do is
just make a simple script and we're
going to say define example or ex
and ex is going to have one parameter
and that's going to be data
now
all this function is going to do is it's
going to print data that's it so now
we're going to go to file
save as
and we're going to save this function in
the same directory as the current script
that we're writing and i'm going to save
it as examplemod.pi
save that and we're done now we can open
up the original script which should be
empty still
come back over here
make it proper size
and now we're ready to maybe use this
module now just real quick we can go
start and what we want to do is we want
to open up a python 3 4 idle
and real quick let's just try to import
example mod
we get an error and it says there's no
module named example mod
basically the path that it's going to go
through to look for modules is going to
be like local site packages
and lib right so see python34lib see
python34
libside packages
generally again third party modules will
be inside packages whereas your typical
vanilla installation modules will be
right there in lib
so with that um we can come over here
though and we can go import example mod
and just real quick let's save and run
it
and we see that we don't actually get an
error okay
and that's because we do have it and
it's local right so it is in one of the
checking checked pads so now what we can
do is we could actually say from well we
have an import example mod now as we
showed in the last video
we still have to do something like this
like example mod examplemod.ex
and then here's where we're going to put
our data for us let's just say a test so
it should just print out test so we'll
save we'll run that
and sure enough the output is
test now we can take this a little step
further
and we can go into the directory that
contains our script which is here so we
have example mod now we can do is go my
computer here c
3 4
lib
site packages and now let's go ahead and
just copy this module into site packages
so now we have example mod in there so
if we go
again to our python 34 idle
what we can do now is import example
mod
and now we can go examplemod.ex
test
and it acts as any other module would
act so that's how you can kind of create
your own modules and you can obviously
edit modules and if you do create your
own modules and it says it doesn't exist
well it needs to be in one of the paths
local
lib site packages okay
and that's pretty much it and so what
you can do eventually is download like
say you're going to say you make your
own script that you find extremely
useful and you you find yourself using
it every time like let's say you
like for me
i do sentiment analysis and a lot of
times i use the same parser for no
matter what the website is i use a
parser and then i usually apply some
rules to it and all that
i'm going to put that in my site
packages because i use it all the time
so why not just import that instead of
for every kind of application that i use
a parser for
uh why not use the one that i've trained
really well so
anyway that's just an example you'll
probably have your own but that's so you
can make your own modules also if you
download someone else's module or maybe
you see someone else's code that you
want to make into a module yourself and
they don't necessarily have a setup to
apply or whatever you can just download
the source right of that module and just
put it in your site packages it's not a
big deal
so anyway that's going to conclude
conclude this video if you guys have any
questions or comments feel free to leave
those below as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and before i go i will
just say obviously if you're in linux or
well any sort of distribution of linux
your path will be different but anyway
um until next time